are you feeling spooky I wonder how many
people are gonna go as Takashi's as the
that chick Jocasta Takashi's 6-9 they're
gonna get some far the 6-9 on their head
and they're gonna do the rainbow bright
hair and they're gonna put some some
guys are gonna put some fake titties in
and they're gonna go as [ __ ] too
cushy 6 9 she's [ __ ] so weirdly sexy
you know I mean I hope she finds a
[ __ ] good guy soon
hey sink ah she's 6 9 why the [ __ ] are
you always so angry you know yeah you've
got Rainbow Brite hair you do whatever
the [ __ ] you want you got tats all over
your body 6 9 is all over your body but
let me ask you pretty little lady why
are you so mad crippled on Chi you've
got a Ferrari painted like the whoever
made the artwork for the Yellow
Submarine of the Beatles you're riding
across Dubai why are you so mad to come
see what the [ __ ] wrong man you got
props why you so upset
qapla Chi say I'm fine I want to know
why you're so upset what's the deal I
swear to god comply she's 6 9 and is you
stupid you thought I could have a
number-one song who thought that I
didn't even think about you why are you
such an upset little girl carte blanche
in 75 why you so mad that's what I want
to know man be ok be happy one day
you'll find a good man and you'll be so
[ __ ] happy you'll make a great
housewife right now thought it up on the
Instagram
anyway shout-out to [ __ ] completed
site sign